do you want that title when all we've
talked about here today and most of it
you've agreed with are things that are
derogatory and so it's like why do you
I don't know I I don't understand and
then and then I'll say both and then you
can both talk but and then for you
you've said you have Traditional Values
and you've you've spoken that a lot but
then you behave like a modern woman and
again it's like what do you what do you
mean in terms of behave like you said
you go out and you said you're into you
were the one that said it I don't
actually know what the behavior is you
know what yeah I'll be honest I'll go
out I go out partying and do that but
majority of the time I get my money from
it like when I dance I get paid to dance
and hype up there like there's this
different like you would have to if a
guy came to me like I feel like when
I'll get in relationships I feel like I
do calm like you delete Instagram for if
your boyfriend asks you to do it
why no but why if okay if you're sharing
recipes maybe yeah let me ask you this
you know I definitely you know your
Instagram page yeah like I don't I don't
know your Instagram page but if I was to
look at it now would you does it look
like a traditional woman on your
Instagram page
what does it look like just like a
typical girl your age you know yeah it
just has modeling pictures my dance
videos
it's nothing to be like upset about or
okay so if you if you met a guy and he
said you know what I'm not really
feeling that I feel like you're
advertising on the internet you're
advertising your body and you know
strange men are getting to look at you
and probably beat their Willies looking
at you and I don't like it can you can
you delete your Instagram deleting is a
stretch I'll compromise I'll definitely
hear him out and I'll I'll shift if
that's that's making you feel really
uncomfortable I will shift I'll change
my style if it's that deep but I'm not
deleting it because I know that's where
I do my business and all that so you're
basically asking me to stop my life you
got I mean
like yeah you have to understand like
when you already came to me you knew
what I was honest you're not in your
business is it would you say like you
can't you kind of have to dress
provocatively
you don't have to you know you don't
have to so if he said that any any
provocative he doesn't want you to post
any provocative pictures anymore and
anything that is on there that is kind
of revealing or kind of sexual he wants
you to delete you'd be cool with that
depends depends on what so if I took my
pitch so as I said back to compromising
I'll take my pictures and I'll send it
to him and I'll see how he reacts I'm
not gonna post it if he's now bugging
out at me like I don't I don't like
problems cool but but if it's like
consistent it's just giving insecure
like it's not insecure it's given no
because what's your ideal what's your
idea of of provocative because really
actually like right now what I'm wearing
is tight cool would you say well I'm
wearing provocative it could be it could
be it could be it can easily be exactly
that way do you go I mean what no I
don't get what you mean what do you mean
I think you're saying within reason that
there's but I think what he's saying is
that it isn't about being within reason
it's about being you know he doesn't
want his girlfriend wife fiance for sale
it's not about being for sale and if you
feel like I'm for sale then get go for
someone else then oh okay
but there's someone that would like me
for who I am
that's modern that traditional well I'm
sure that I do have children but I'm
saying like from what from what you've
said I haven't heard you say anything
about yourself that's traditional
because even you said much about it no
but I'm saying like so so when you're
saying you're saying that you won't
listen because before you were saying
you wanted to be the support system to
your guy but when he gives you an order
and tells you to do something you don't
want to listen because you don't like it
earlier you said you liked the idea of
supporting a man did you know but who
said that I wouldn't listen though
because you you just said that now you
said within reason so that the whole
point is that you're cool it's called
compromising because if you came to me
and I already had my things set out for
myself you'll come and you're like stop
cool you need to come to me with
something to make me want to stop black
so basically the guy has what can I
monitor no let me let me for example I
was listening to you like in terms of
your relationship with your man like and
he came to you and said I have this idea
if he came to me on that kind of flex
I'm not gonna lie if I saw that Vision
with you I would I'm there with you but
me I know already started my thing I was
single before I was with you so I was
doing what I was doing and you came to
me you approached me as you said guys
approach the woman and I went with it
cool you know I wasn't you met me I can
compromise I can't change I can't change
you see you see when you say that yeah
that basically puts you in a horrible
position because now you just you've
just graduated yourself to recreational
use what do you mean what do you mean
what do I mean you know exactly I just
mean like listen listen a guy has is is
approaching you and he seems like he
wants to take you seriously that's why
he doesn't want his woman advertising on
Instagram explore page but I wouldn't be
like like this is the thing I don't know
because you haven't seen me because you
haven't seen my in my position yeah but
I asked you your opinion I asked you
your opinion I asked you is it is listen
I asked you does it look like the
typical girl your age is Instagram page
and you said yeah so
like in terms of style you're going on
style different types okay cool is it is
there is there a lot of provocative
images on your Instagram page
I don't think there is you don't think
there is can we bring it up on screen
and Mom will decide
me I don't even mind I'm not a shy thing
you know I will show you do you want to
see my Instagram just quickly show he
can do it just quickly
she has if she has pictures on bikini
who cares I don't that's the thing I
don't do that so okay
let me see it let me see it go ahead and
shoot I think that's me because
this one mom
which one
let me see
just say let her let her see which one
okay
that's provocative to you
I don't know I mean provocative or not
what I would say is that I don't think
my husband would be super excited about
me
think about think about the listen this
is the thing you're not thinking about
it from a man's point of view the man
that is actually committing to you think
about it like
you're kind of thinking of it selfishly
and thinking it just from your own
selfish listen listen listen listen
listen listen listen listen this is what
I'm saying you're not even listening
you're doing whatever now like you're
not looking from the man's point of view
that man that man who's deciding to
commit to you provision and protection
no one wants to provide and protect a
girl that's for everybody or a girl that
can be accessed by any strange guy with
his Willy in his hand on Instagram I'm
sorry they don't and also when you when
you put out pictures that can be seen as
provocative maybe not by you but maybe
the rest of the world look at it like
that it's advertising
that's what it is to me when I look at
those pictures I mean you're beautiful
and so when I look at those pictures I
see
provocative Behavior not necessarily
like the outfits weren't necessarily you
know nothing was hanging out necessarily
but it looked provocative the way you
were sitting was provocative and so to
me that's that doesn't make the guy feel
good like he wants to be in yeah I mean
you were kind of straddling emotions
that was a video shoot so it was it was
yeah but I think that women like to they
like to see themselves and they like to
see themselves as beautiful I like to
see myself as beautiful I looked like
her outfit a few hours ago
you don't like so don't you kind of see
you like like I know you may feel like
oh everyone's coming at you but do you
kind of understand the point
listen listen listen listen listen
listen
yeah do you get what
okay do you get what I was trying to say
to you do you understand this in any way
about like why the guy will tell you if
a guy actually really likes you and
wants to commit to you and sees a
long-term future with you why he would
say that is advertising I want you to
get rid of all of it
you don't see that I already said what I
would do yeah but yeah
it's hurting so I feel like everything
I'm saying is being dismissed no this is
this is me single I get it cool with the
guy you're not single no more exactly
and I already said what I would do when
I'm not using it you'd consider it yeah
so I came to I said I would take steps
in that as in I would show him the
pictures if he thinks it's provocative I
won't post it I literally said that yeah
all right okay and you would be if you
felt confident that he would you know he
was husband material or that you were
gonna be a thing that you would delete
your Instagram and get on his bus yeah
if I feel like he was the one the one
I'm not gonna lie I would okay that's
fair that's good that's good stuff you
were the lit as well oh girl I don't
care about Instagram
[Laughter]
like honestly I really
I I have management run it half the time
anyway would you delete your Instagram
of course not never why I have my life I
have my personality and relationship
because if you start with this kind of
insecurity what's come next like when
the real problem came up like oh you're
a bikinis guys are watching your body
okay why why why do you want strange
event to be able to have access to your
pictures in your bikini just because I
think we need to educate men women we
need to be covering our bar because man
can't control themselves but we don't
see happen with man that's not the
question I asked you no it is because
it's like in a divert it's like Oh I'm a
naked on my Instagram
no I'm asking about your psychology you
why do you want strange men to look at
you in your bikini on Instagram
why do you want them to have access why
is your Instagram private it's private
yes I like to post things I feel too I
don't want to give an explanation if I'm
in the beach and I want to take a
picture and post why not oh because like
maybe a guy is gonna look at me like you
know it's so crazy how we manage to be
taking care because of
men all the time you know all the time
my men is the guy that you're with no
sometimes it's for the guys women are
blaming for a grape because of the
things they are wearing at the day oh
she was wearing Seven Something
provocative like come on which word
we're living listen listen listen at the
end of the day there's good and bad in
every demographic there's always going
to be degenerates and dysfunctional
people in every demographic like do you
get what I'm saying so like bringing up
grape is I mean I hear I get what you're
saying but like there's always going to
be bad eggs by the end of the day at the
end of the day like we're talking about
in a situation where your man who is
committed to you who's protecting and
providing for you remember he's willing
to probably risk his life every time
he's outside with you or even in the
house because if something happens at
3am in the morning you're gonna want him
to go downstairs not you
but again that's very underrated amongst
modern women that protection aspect
until something bad happens now oh yeah
I want a big man to bro like
you have a problem just with your social
media that you're not making money from
that's not doing anything for you it's
just vanity
it's just vanity that's all it is
but people should feel free so why can't
so what I'm asking you is why how can
you not see that that vanity aspect is
not more important than a guy that is
protecting and providing for you
wow because that is the kind of
relationship I would not like to be in I
think people should post to do what they
feel to do it and are intervention no
it's like the guy you're telling me like
if you're insecure he feels like that
I'm showing my body not that I'm saying
I have a pictures on bikini but it's
pointless in a relationship social media
have this here's an asking he isn't
asking you not to do that for him he's
asking you not to do it for the creepy
guy in his apartment
the word is full of creepy guys Wherever
I Go believe me I know but he's asking
if I would take it off because of a
boyfriend if he's asking me like oh we
are in a serious relationship and
feeling confident like
no but he's not saying he's incompetent
he's saying he doesn't want to share you
with the world yeah this is his opinion
but of course a strong-minded guy won't
care about social media at all because
he's not planning on wifing you up
I think it's the kind of guy you're
describing will be never the kind of guy
who will go out with
a start like
if a social Media Matters he's like what
if you're talking about a provocative
pictures it's like we should you know
like advertise I don't understand how
you don't understand his advertising I
don't understand how many how many
millionaire men do you know like a lot
how many how many do you know any like
multi like 10 20 30 40 50 millionaire
man okay
um the women that they pick would they
have an issue taking down their
Instagrams typically they wouldn't have
an Instagram and start there Instagram
yeah yeah I just got one
it's personal no no but I'm saying
that's that like that's the men with the
most options right the richest most
successful men in general in society
tend to have more options with women
right for sure yeah I mean you could
argue looks goes in there too but at the
end of the day girls want a guy they can
build a family with so the men with the
most options they're not putting up with
that right they would not like it's just
not I can't think of one I mean I'm sure
there are there's lots of politicians
and famous people that are but in the
world that I've lived in absolutely yeah
but there you put his success in money I
know a lot of well-educated people who
are normalcy millionaire but they're
very respect people and I think that
this difference what is success for you
if we would be a millionaire but for for
other people be someone very well
educated it depends on the values no I'm
not I'm not
I'm not talking about success I'm
talking about successful with women so
the men that most women want to be with
most men women want to feel taken care
of and a lot of the guys they and I know
she knows them because like I grew up
around a lot of like these people were
coming in and out of our house I saw
them at the business whatever like
they're they're guys in good shape too
like they're attractive men that a lot
of women would want to be with and they
they're family guys like a lot of them
have families their wives aren't on
Instagram and they wouldn't have a
problem taking their Instagrams down so
it's like if you want to sell a car you
got to study the buyer what do the
buyers want what are the best buyers
looking for they feel I'm not sure for
sure but if you are adults this doesn't
really matter but that's my opinion but
I think I think that's where I'm trying
to say to you is that it it
the reality that you're trying to create
doesn't exist like the men that there's
not a man on the planet that would be
super excited about his future wife
showing her body all over the planet
like that's true the supermodels will be
be all single right well they have a
hard time staying married I think that
is value I think it's a background
country as well I think Europe is much
different in different values as well
and of course like you're gonna talk
about the America's millionaire that is
a different niche of thanks God in
Europe the millionaire Niche is
completely different I think the image
in America is really important to you to
maintain the perfect family blah blah
blah but in Europe I feel people free to
do I see single people at the 40 no one
cares no one talk about their lives
people not say like oh she didn't get
married people here are very very
reserved which I love that's reason I
live in Europe because people here would
do like coming comments to you when
you're out like lots of carries in
America whatever they say what's right
what's wrong I think there is what is
right for you at the first place we
should not give in labels here because
there is no labels people are free to be
who they just said listen I think the
reality is reality and all you have to
do is look at the statistics and look at
what's happening so you can say who you
want about oh you shouldn't say this she
didn't say that until you fail and then
you're going to be like oh you're gonna
be one of these girls not you personally
but the one these women are going to be
one of these people on Tick Tock these
older women that are crying oh my God I
went on Tinder and I'm still trying to
date Chad and Tyrone and I drove three
hours to go meet him and we just ate
pizza and yeah we smashed and then I
went home and then he didn't call me
back yeah recreational use
like at the end of the day if you just
don't accept reality and you try to mold
it into what you I don't know you just
believe it's like this I'm sorry bro if
everybody's telling you that it's one
way if the statistics show you that is
one way that's what it is
like and Brett like I didn't think he's
I'm not trying to save the whole world I
mean I'm just saying I'm just a reporter
of reality at the end of the day like
you can think you can live whatever way
you want to live but at the end of the
day you're an adult so when it all goes
to pot you ain't got no one to blame and
don't blame men or it's because of men
men of this manner that night you you
lost because of your choices I also live
in a timing that your reality is not the
other people reality you need to
understand that we're human beings we're
human beings
we're human beings we're not that way we
all live in the same world but we are in
the different bubbles let's say the
people the traditional people who look
for traditional kind of relationships
they lives in a bubble yeah we don't go
to the same Starbucks we don't go to the
same mall we go to we all interact it's
delusional if we think that we live
you know in the separate separatist
world I mean even the comments about
America this America that we have very
we have lived a very global life I've
had Europeans live in my house for most
of my adult life I know America sounds
like Brazil is full of immigrants but my
point it is is about it is
when you say people oh die alone oh blah
blah blah I think it's perspective and
of course which data you're looking for
who did this data what's the reason was
a marketing campaign so for me it's
actually do you think okay your opinion
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible